[SQUEAKING]
PROFESSOR: Last time, we
started discussing graph limits.
And let me remind you some of
the notions and definitions
that were involved.
One of the main
objects in graph limits
is that of a graphon, which are
symmetric, measurable functions
from the unit squared
to the unit interval.
So here, symmetric means
that w of x, comma, y
equals to w of y, comma, x.
We define a notion
of convergence
for a sequence of graphons.
And remember, the
notion of convergence
is that a sequence is convergent
if the sequence of homomorphism
densities converges as n goes
to infinity for every fixed
F, every fixed graph.
So this is how we
define convergence.
So a sequence of
graphs or graphons,
they converge if all the
homomorphism densities--
so you should think of this
as subgraph statistics--
if all of these
statistics converge.
We also say that a sequence
converges to a particular limit
if these homomorphism
densities converge
to the corresponding
homomorphism density
of the limit for every F.
OK.
So this is how we
define convergence.
We also define this
notion of a distance.
And to do that, we
first define the cut
norm to be the following
quantity defined
by taking two subsets, S
and T, which are measurable.
Everything so far is
going to be measurable.
And look at what is the
maximum possible deviation
of the integral of this
function on this box, S cross T.
And here, w, you should think
of it as taking real values,
allowing both positive
and negative values,
because otherwise,
you should just
take S and T to be
the whole interval.
OK.
And this definition
was motivated
by our discussion of discrepancy
coming from quasi randomness.
Now, if I give you
two graphs or graphons
and ask you to
compare them, you are
allowed to permute the
vertices in some sense,
so to find the best overlay.
And that notion is
captured in the definition
of cut distance, which is
defined to be the following
quantity, where we consider over
all possible measure-preserving
bijections from the interval
to itself of the difference
between these two
graphons if I rotate
one of them using this
measure-preserving bijection.
So think of this as
permuting the vertices.
So these were the definitions
that were involved last time.
And at the end of
last lecture, I
stated three main theorems
of graph limit theory.
So I forgot to
mention what are some
of the histories of this theory.
So there were a number
of important papers
that developed this very idea of
graph limits, which is actually
somewhat-- if you think
about all of combinatorics,
we like to deal with
discrete objects.
And even the idea of taking
a limit is rather novel.
So this work is due
to a number of people.
In particular, Laszlo Lovasz
played a very important
central role in the
development of this theory.
And various people
came to this theory
from different
perspectives-- some
from more pure
perspectives, and some
from more applied perspectives.
And this theory is now getting
used in more and more places,
including statistics,
machine learning, and so on.
And I'll explain where that
comes up just a little bit.
At the end of last lecture,
I stated three main theorems.
And what I want to do
today is develop some tools
so that we can prove those
theorems in the next lecture.
OK.
So I want to develop some tools.
In particular, you'll see some
of the things that we've talked
about in the chapter on
Szemerédi's regularity lemma
come up again in a slightly
different language.
So much of what I will say
today hopefully should already
be familiar to you, but
you will see it again
from the perspective
of graph limits.
But first, before telling
you about the tools,
I want to give you
some more examples.
So one of the ways that
I motivated graph limits
last time is this example of
an Erdos-Renyi random graph
or a sequence of quasi-random
graphs converging
to a constant.
The constant graphon
is the limit.
But what about generalizations?
What about generalizations
of that construction when
your limit is not the constant?
So this leads to this idea
of a w random graph, which
generalizes that of an
Erdos-Renyi random graph.
So in Erdos-Renyi, we're
looking at every edge occurring
with the same probability, p,
uniform throughout the graph.
But what I want to do now is
allow you to change the edge
probability somewhat.
OK.
So before giving you the
more general definition,
a special case of this
is an important model
of random graphs known as
the stochastic block model.
And in particular, a two-block
model consists of the following
data where I am looking
at two types of vertices--
let's call them red and blue--
where the vertices are
assigned to colors at random--
for example, 50/50.
But any other
probability is fine.
And now I put down the edges
according to which colors
the two endpoints are.
So two red vertices are joined
with edge probability Prr.
If I have a red
and a blue, then I
may have a different probability
joining them, and likewise
with blue-blue, like that.
So in other words, I can encode
this probability information
in the matrix, like that.
So it's symmetric
across the diagonal.
So this is a slightly
more general version
of an Erdos-Renyi
random graph where now I
have potentially different
types of vertices.
And you can imagine
these kinds of models
are very important in
applied mathematics
for modeling certain situations
such as, for example,
if you have people with
different political party
affiliations.
How likely are they
to talk to each other?
So you can imagine
some of these numbers
might be bigger than others.
And there's an important
statistical problem.
If I give you a graph, can
you cluster or classify
the vertices according
to their types
if I do not show you in advance
what the colors are but show
you what the output graph is?
So these are important
statistical questions
with lots of applications.
This is an example of if
you have only two blocks.
But of course, you can
have more than two blocks.
And the graphon context
tells us that we should not
limit ourselves to just blocks.
If I give you any
graphon w, I can also
construct a random graph.
So what I would like
to do is to consider
the following
construction where--
OK, so let's just call
it w random graph denoted
by g and w--
where I form the graph
using the following process.
First, the vertex set is
labeled by 1 through n.
And let me draw the vertex types
by taking uniform random x1
through xn--
OK, so uniform iid.
So you think of them as the
vertex colors, the vertex
types.
And I put an edge
between i and j
with probability
exactly w of xi,
xj, so for all i less
than j independently.
That's the definition
of a w random graph.
And the two-block
stochastic model
is a special case of
this w random graph
for the graphon,
which corresponds
to this red-blue picture here.
So the generation process would
be I give you some x1, x2, x3,
and then, likewise, x1, x3, x2.
And then I evaluate, what
is the value of this graphon
at these points?
And those are my
edge probabilities.
So what I described
is a special case
of this general w random graph.
Any questions?
So like before, an important
statistical question
is if I show you
the graph, can you
tell me a good model for
where this graph came from?
So that's one of the reasons
why people in applied math
might care about these
types of constructions.
Let me talk about some theorems.
I've told you that the sequence
of Erdos-Renyi random graphs
converges to the
constant graphon p.
So instead of taking
a constant graphon p,
now I start with w random graph.
And you should expect,
and it is indeed true,
that this sequence converges
to w as their limit.
So let w be a graphon.
And for each n, let me
draw this graph G sub
n using the w random
graph model independently.
Then with probability
1, the sequence
converges to the graphon w.
So in the sense that I've
shown above, described above.
So this statement
tells us a couple
of things-- one, that w random
graphs converge to the limit w,
as you should expect; and
two, that every graphon w
is the limit point of
some sequence of graphs.
So this is something that
we never quite explicitly
stated before.
So let me make this remark.
So in particular,
every w is the limit
of some sequence of graphs,
just like every real number,
in analogy to what
we said last time.
Every real number is
the limit of a sequence
of rational numbers through
rational approximation.
And this is some form of
approximation of a graphon
by a sequence of graphs.
OK.
So I'm not going to
prove this theorem.
The proof is not difficult.
So using that definition
of subgraph
convergence, the proof
uses what's known as
Azuma's inequality.
So by an appropriate application
of Azuma's inequality
on the concentration
of martingales,
one can prove this
theorem here by estimating
the probability that--
to show that the probability
that the F density in Gn,
it is very close to
the F density in w
with high probability.
OK.
Any questions so far?
So this is an important
example of one
of the motivations
of graph limits.
But now, let's get back
to what I said earlier.
I would like to develop
a sequence of tools
that will allow us to prove
the main theorem stated
at the end of the last lecture.
And this will sound
very familiar,
because we're going to write
down some lemmas that we did
back in the chapter of
Szemerédi's regularity lemma
but now in the
language of graphons.
So the first is
a counting lemma.
The goal of the
counting lemma is
to show that if you
have two graphons which
are close to each other in the
sense of cut distance, then
their F densities are
similar to each other.
So here's a statement.
So if w and u are
graphons and F is
a graph, then the F density
of w minus the F density of u,
their difference is no more
than a constant-- so number
of edges of F times the cut
distance between u and w.
So maybe some of you already
see how to do this from
our discussion on
Szemerédi's regularity lemma.
In any case, I want to just
rewrite the proof again
in the language of graphons.
And this will hopefully--
so we did two proofs of the
triangle counting lemma.
One was hopefully more
intuitive for you,
which is you pick a
typical vertex that
has lots of neighbors
on both sides
and therefore lots
of edges between.
And then there was a
second proof, which I said
was a more analytic
proof, where you took out
one edge at a time.
And that proof, I think
it's technically easier
to implement, especially
for general H.
But the first time
you see it, you
might not quite see what
the calculation was about.
So I want to do this exact
same calculation again
in the language of graphons.
And hopefully, it should
be clear this time.
So this is the same
as the counting lemma
over epsilon-regular pairs.
So it suffices to
prove the inequality
where the right-hand side
is replaced not by the cut
distance but by the cut norm.
And the reason is that once
you have the second inequality
by taking an infimum over all
measure-preserving bijections
phi--
and notice that that change
does not affect the F density.
By taking an infimum
over phi, you
recover the first inequality.
I want to give you a small
reformulation of the cut norm
that will be useful for thinking
about this counting lemma.
Here's a reformulation
of the cut norm--
namely, that I can
define the cut norm.
So here, w is taking
real values, so
not necessarily non-negative.
So the cut norm
we saw earlier is
defined to be the supremum
over all measurable subsets
of the 0, 1 interval of this
integral in absolute value.
But it turns out I can rewrite
this supremum over a slightly
larger set of objects.
Instead of just looking
over measurable subsets
of the interval, let me now
look at measurable functions.
Little u.
So OK, let me look at functions.
So u and v from 0, 1 to 0, 1--
and as always, everything
is measurable--
of the following integral.
So I claim this is true.
So I consider this integral.
Instead of integrating
over a box,
now I'm integrating
this expression.
OK.
So why is this true?
Well, one of the
directions is easy to see,
because the right-hand side
is strictly an enlargement
of the left-hand side.
So by taking u to be the
indicator function of S
and v to be the indicator
of function of T,
you see that the
right-hand side, in fact,
includes the left-hand
side in terms
of what you are allowed to do.
But what about the
other direction?
So for the other
direction, the main thing
is to notice that the
integral or the integrand,
what's inside this integral,
is bilinear in the values of u
and v. So in particular, the
extrema of this integral,
as you allow to vary u
and v, they are obtained.
So they are obtained
for u and v,
taking values in the
endpoints 0, comma, 1.
It may be helpful to think about
the discrete setting, when,
instead of this integral, you
have a matrix and two vectors
multiplied from left and right.
And you had to decide,
what are the coordinates
of those vectors?
It's a bilinear form.
How do you maximize
it or minimize it?
You have to change every entry
to one of its two endpoints.
Otherwise, it can never be--
you never lose by doing that.
OK, so think about it.
So this is not difficult once
you see it the right way.
But now, we have this cut
norm expressed over not sets,
but over bounded functions.
And now I'm ready to
prove the counting lemma.
And instead of writing down
the whole proof for general H,
let me write down the
calculation that illustrates
this proof for triangles.
And the general
proof is the same
once you understand how
this argument works.
And the argument works by
considering the difference
between these two F densities.
And what I want to do is--
so this is some integral, right?
So this is this integral,
which I'll write out.
So we would like to show
that this quantity here
is small if u and w
are close in cut norm.
So let's write this integral
as a telescoping sum
where the first term
is obtained by--
so by this, I mean
w of x, comma, y
minus u of x, comma, y.
And then the second term
of the telescoping sum--
so you see what happens.
I change one factor at a time.
And finally, I change
the third factor.
So this is the identity.
If you expand out all
of these differences,
you see that everything
intermediate cancels out.
So it's a telescoping sum.
But now I want to show
that each term is small.
So how can I show that
each term is small?
Look at this expression here.
I claim that for a
fixed value of z--
so imagine fixing z.
And let x and y vary
in this integral.
It has the form up there, right?
If you fix z, then
you have this u and v
coming from these two factors.
And they are both
bounded between 0 and 1.
So for a fixed value of z,
this is at most w minus u--
the cut norm difference between
w and u in absolute value.
So if I left z vary, it is
still bounded in absolute value
by that quantity.
So therefore each is
bounded by w minus u cut
norm in absolute value.
Add all three of them together.
We find that the whole thing
is bounded in absolute value
by 3 times the cut
normal difference.
OK, and that finishes the
proof of the counting lemma.
For triangles, of course,
if you have general H,
then you just have more terms.
You have a longer telescoping
sum, and you have this bound.
OK.
So this is a counting lemma.
And I claim that it's exactly
the same proof as the second
proof of the counting lemma
that we did when we discussed
Szemerédi's regularity lemma
and this counting lemma.
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why did it suffice
to prove over the [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let me answer
that in a second.
So first, this should
be H, not F. OK,
so your question
was, up there, why
was it sufficient to
prove this version instead
of that version?
Is that the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Suppose I prove it
for this version.
So I know this is true.
Now I take infimum
of both sides.
So now I consider
infimum of both sides.
So then this is true, right?
Because it's true for every phi.
But the left-hand side doesn't
change, because the F density
in a relabeling of the vertices,
it's still the same quantity,
whereas this one
here is now that.
All right.
So what we see as a corollary
of this counting lemma
is that if you are a Cauchy
sequence with respect
to the cut distance,
then the sequence
is automatically convergent.
So recall the definition
of convergence.
Convergence has to do with
F densities converging.
And if you have a
Cauchy sequence,
then the F densities converge.
And also, a related
but different statement
is that if you have
a sequence wn that
converges to w in
cut distance, then
it implies that wn
converges to w in the sense
as defined for F densities.
So qualitatively, what
the counting lemma says
is that the cut norm is stronger
than the notion of convergence
coming from subgraph densities.
So this is one part of
this regularity method, so
the counting lemma.
Of course, the other part is
the regularity lemma itself.
So that's the next
thing we'll do.
And it turns out
that we actually
don't need the full strength
of the regularity lemma.
We only need something called
a weak regularity lemma.
What the weak regularity
lemma says is--
I mean, you still have a
partition of the vertices.
So let me now state
it for graphons.
So for a partition p--
so I have a partition
of the vertex set--
and a symmetric,
measurable function w--
I'm just going to omit the
word "measurable" from now on.
Everything will be measurable.
What I can do is, OK,
all of these assets
are also measurable.
I can define what's known as a
stepping operator that sends w
to this object,
w sub p, obtained
by averaging over
the steps si cross sj
and replacing that graphon by
its average over each step.
Precisely, so I
obtain a new graphon,
a new symmetric, measurable
function, w sub p,
where the value on x,
comma, y is defined
to be the following quantity--
if x, comma, y lies
in si cross sj.
So pictorially, what happens is
that you look at your graphon.
There's a partition
of the vertex set,
so to speak, the interval.
Doesn't have to be a
partition into intervals,
but for illustration,
suppose it looks like that.
And what I do is I take
this w, and I replace it
by a new graphon, a new
symmetric, measurable function,
w sub p, obtained by averaging.
Take each box.
Replace it by its average.
Put that average into the box.
So this is what w sub
p is supposed to be.
Just a few minor technicalities.
If this denominator is equal
to 0, let's ignore the set.
I mean, then you have a
zero measure set, anyway,
so we ignore that set.
So everything will be
treated up to measure zero,
changing the function
on measure zero sets.
So it doesn't really matter
if you're not strictly
allowed to do this division.
OK.
So this operator plays
an important role
in the regularity
lemma, because it's
how we think about partitioning,
what happens to a graph
under partitioning.
It has several other names if
you look at it from slightly
different perspectives.
So you can view
it as a projection
in the sense of Hilbert space.
So in the Hilbert space of
functions on the unit square,
the stepping operator is a
projection unto the subspace
of constants,
subspace of functions
that are constant on each step.
So that's one interpretation.
Another interpretation is
that this operation is also
a conditional expectation.
If you know what a conditional
expectation actually
is in the sense of
probability theory,
so then that's
what happens here.
If you view 0, 1 squared
as a probability space,
then what we're doing is we're
doing conditional expectation
relative to the sigma algebra
generated by these steps.
So these are just a
couple of ways of thinking
about what's going on.
They might be somewhat
helpful later on
if you're familiar
with these notions.
But if you're not,
don't worry about it.
Concretely, it's what
happens up there.
OK.
So now let me state the
weak regularity lemma.
So the weak regularity
lemma is attributed
to Frieze and Kannan,
although their work predates
the language of graphons.
So it's stated in the
language of graphs,
but it's the same proof.
So let me state it for you
both in terms of graphons
and in graphs.
What it says is that for every
epsilon and every graphon w,
there exists a partition
denoted p of the 0, 1 interval.
And now I tell you how
many sets there are.
So it's a partition into--
so not a tower-type
number of parts,
but only roughly an
exponential number of parts--
4 to the 1 over epsilon
squared measurable sets such
that if we apply the stepping
operator to this graphon,
we obtain an approximation of
the graphon in the cut norm.
So that's the statement of
the weak regularity lemma.
There exists a partition such
that if you do this stepping,
then you obtain
an approximation.
So I want you to think about
what this has to do with
the usual version of Szemerédi's
regularity lemma that
you've seen earlier.
So hopefully, you
should realize, morally,
they're about the same
types of statements.
But more importantly, how are
they different from each other?
And now let me state a version
for graphs, which is similar
but not exactly the same as
what we just saw for graphons.
So let me state it.
So for graphs, the
weak regularity lemma
says that, OK, so for graphs,
let me define a partition
p of the vertex set is
called weakly epsilon regular
if the following is true.
If it is the case that whenever
I look at two vertex subsets,
A and B, of the
vertex set of g, then
the number of vertices
between A and B
is what you should expect based
on the density information that
comes out of this partition.
Namely, if I sum over all
the parts of the partition,
look at how many vertices from A
lie in the corresponding parts.
And then multiply by the edge
density between these parts.
So that's your predicted
value based on the data that
comes out of the partition.
So I claim that this is
the actual number of edges.
This is the predicted
number of edges.
And those two numbers should
be similar to each other bt
at most epsilon n, where n
is the number of vertices.
So this is the definition of
what it means for a partition
to be weakly epsilon regular.
So it's important to think
about why this is weaker.
It's called weak, right?
So why is it weaker than a
notion of epsilon regularity?
So why is it weaker?
So previously, we had
epsilon-regular partition
in the definition of
Szemerédi's regularity lemma,
this epsilon-regular partition.
And here, notion of
weakly epsilon regular.
So why is this a lot weaker?
It is not saying that
individual pairs of parts
are epsilon regular.
And eventually, we're going
to have this number of parts.
So I'll state a
theorem in a second.
So the sizes of the
parts are much smaller
than epsilon fraction.
But what this weak notion of
regularity says, if you look
at it globally--
so not looking at
specific parts,
but looking at it globally--
then this partition is
a good approximation
of what's going on in the
actual graph, whereas--
OK, so it's worth
thinking about.
It's really worth
thinking about what's
the difference between this weak
notion and the usual notion.
But first, let me state
this regularity lemma.
So the weak regularity
lemma for graphs
says that for every
epsilon and every graph G,
there exists a weakly
epsilon-regular partition
of the vertex set
of G into at most 4
to the 1 over epsilon
squared parts.
Now, you might wonder why
did Frieze and Kannan come up
with this notion of regularity.
It's a weaker result if you
don't care about the bounds,
because an epsilon-regular
partition will be automatically
weakly epsilon regular.
So maybe with small
changes of epsilon
if you wish, but basically,
this is a weaker notion
compared to what we had before.
But of course, the advantage
is that you have a much more
reasonable number of parts.
It's not a tower.
It's just a single exponential.
And this is important.
And their motivation was a
computer science and algorithm
application.
So I want to take a
brief detour and mention
why you might care about weakly
epsilon-regular partitions.
In particular, the problem
that is of interest
is in approximating
something called a max cut.
So the max cut problem asks you
to determine-- given a graph G,
find the maximum over
all subsets of vertices,
the maximum number of
vertices between a set
and its complement.
That's called a cut.
I give you a graph,
and I want to know--
find this s so that it
can have as many edges
across this set as possible.
This is an important
problem in computer science,
extremely important problem.
And the status of
this problem is
that it is known to be difficult
to get it even within 1%.
So the best algorithm is due
to Goemans and Williamson.
It's an important
algorithm that was
one of the
foundational algorithms
in semidefinite
programming, so related--
the words "semidefinite
programming"
came up earlier in this course
when we discussed growth index
inequality.
So they came up with an
approximation algorithm.
So here, I'm only talking
about polynomial time,
so efficient algorithms.
Approximation algorithm
with approximation ratio
around 0.878.
So one can obtain a cut
that is within basically
13% of the maximum.
So it's an
approximation algorithm.
However, it is known that it is
hard in the sense of complexity
theory.
It'd be hard to approximate
beyond the ratio 16 over 17,
which is around 0.491.
And there is an
important conjecture
in computer science called
a unique games conjecture
that, if that
conjecture were true,
then it would be
difficult. It would
be hard to approximate beyond
the Goemans-Williamson ratio.
So this indicates the
status of this problem.
It is difficult to do an
epsilon approximation.
But if the graph I
give you is dense--
"dense" meaning a
quadratic number
of edges, where n is
a number of vertices--
then it turns out that the
regularity-type algorithms--
so that theorem combined
with the algorithmic versions
allows you to get polynomial
time approximation algorithms.
So this is polynomial time
approximation schemes.
So one can approximate up
to 1 minus epsilon ratio.
So one can approximate
up to epsilon
n squared additive error
in polynomial time.
So in particular, if I'm
willing to lose 0.01 n squared,
then there is an algorithm to
approximate the size of the max
cut.
And that algorithm
basically comes from--
without giving you any
details whatsoever,
the algorithm essentially comes
from first finding a regularity
partition.
So the partition breaks
the set of vertices
into some number of pieces.
And now I search over
all possible ratios
to divide each piece.
So there is a bounded
number of parts.
Each one of those, I decide,
do I cut this up half-half?
Do I cut it up 1/3,
2/3, and so on?
And those numbers alone,
because of this definition
of weakly epsilon
regular, once you
know what the intersection
of A, B is, let's say,
a complement is with
individual sets,
then I basically know
the number of edges.
So I can approximate
the size of the max cut
using a weakly
epsilon-regular partition.
So that was the motivation
for these weakly epsilon
partitions, at least the
algorithmic application.
OK.
Any questions?
So let's take a quick break.
And then afterwards,
I want to show
you the proof of the
weak regularity lemma.
All right.
So let me start the proof of
the weak regularity lemma.
And the proof is by this
energy increment argument.
So let's see what
this energy increment
argument looks like in
the language of graphons.
So energy now means L2,
so L2 energy increment.
So the statement
of this lemma is
that if you have w, a graphon,
and p, a partition, of 0,
comma, 1 interval such that--
always measurable pieces.
I'm not going to even write it.
It's always measurable pieces--
such that the difference between
w and w averaged over steps p
is bigger than epsilon.
So this is the notion
of being not epsilon
regular in the weak sense,
not weakly epsilon regular.
Then there exists a
refinement, p prime of p,
dividing each part of p
into at most four parts
such that the true norm
increases by more than epsilon
squared under this refinement.
So it should be similar.
It should be familiar to
you, because we have similar
arguments from Szemerédi's
regularity lemma.
So let's see the proof.
Because you have violation
of weak epsilon regularity,
there exists sets S and T,
measurable subsets of 0,
1 interval, such that this
integral evaluated over S
cross T is more than
epsilon in absolute value.
So now let me take p prime to
be the common refinement of p
by introducing S and
T into this partition.
So throw S and T in
and break everything
according to S and T.
And so each part becomes
at most four subparts.
So that's the at
most four subparts.
I now need to show that I
have an energy increment.
And to do this, let
me first perform
the following calculation.
So remember, this symbol
here is the inner product
obtained by multiplying
and integrating
over the entire box.
I claim that that
inner product equals
to the inner product
between wp and wp prime,
because what happens here is
we are looking at a situation
where wp prime is
constant on each part.
So when I do this inner product,
I can replace w by its average.
And likewise, over here, I can
also replace it by its average.
And you end up having
the same average.
And these two averages
are both just what happens
if you do stepping by p.
You also have that w has inner
product with 1 sub S cross T
the same as that of p
prime by the same reason,
because over S
cross T. So S cross
T is a union of the
parts of p prime.
So S is union of
OK.
So let's see.
With those observations,
you find that--
so this is true.
This is from the first equality.
So now let me draw
you a right triangle.
So you have a right
angle, because you have
an inner product that is 0.
So by Pythagorean theorem,
so what is this hypotenuse?
So you add these two vectors.
And you find out this wp prime.
So by Pythagorean
theorem, you find
that the L2 norm
of wp prime equals
to the L2 norm of the sum of
the L2 norm squares of the two
legs of this right triangle.
On the other hand,
this quantity here.
So let's think about
that quantity over there.
It's an L2 norm.
So in particular, it is at
least this quantity here,
which you can derive
in one of many ways--
for example, by Cauchy-Schwarz
inequality or go from L2 to L1
and then pass down to L1.
So this is true.
So let's say by Cauchy-Schwarz.
But this quantity here, we
said was bigger than epsilon.
So as a result,
this final quantity,
this L2 norm of
the new refinement,
increases from the previous one
by more than epsilon squared.
OK.
So this is the L2 energy
increment argument.
I claim it's the same
argument, basically,
as the one that we did for
Szemerédi's regularity lemma.
And I encourage you to
go back and compare them
to see why they're the same.
All right, moving on.
So the other part
of regularity lemma
is to iterate this approach.
So if you have something
which is not epsilon regular,
refine it.
And then iterate.
And you cannot perceive more
than a bounded number of times,
because energy is always
bounded between 0 and 1.
So for every epsilon bigger
than 0 and graphon w,
suppose you have P0, a
partition of 0, 1 interval
into measurable sets.
Then there exists a partition
p that cuts up each part of P0
into at most 4 to the
1 over epsilon parts
such that w minus w sub
p is at most epsilon.
So I'm basically restating
the weak regularity lemma
over there but with a
small difference, which
will become useful later on
when we prove compactness.
Namely, I'm allowed to
start with any partition.
Instead of starting with
a trivial partition,
I can start with any partition.
This was also true when
we were talking about
Szemerédi's regularity lemma,
although I didn't stress that
point.
That's certainly the case here.
I mean, the proof
is exactly the same
with or without this extra.
This extra P0 really plays
an insignificant role.
What happens, as in the proof
of Szemerédi's regularity lemma,
is that we repeatedly apply
the previous lemma to obtain
the sequence of partitions
of the 0, 1 interval where,
each step, either we find that
we obtain some partition p sub
i such that it's a good
approximation of w,
in which case we stop, or the
L2 energy increases by more than
epsilon squared.
And since the final energy
is always at most 1--
so it's always bounded
between 0 and 1--
we must stop after at
most 1 over epsilon steps.
And if you calculate
the number of parts,
each part is subdivided
into at most four parts
at each step, which
gives you the conclusion
on the final number of parts.
OK, so very similar
to what we did before.
All right.
So that concludes the discussion
of the weak regularity lemma.
So basically the same proof.
Weaker conclusion and
better quantitative balance.
The next thing and the final
thing I want to discuss today
is a new ingredient which
we haven't seen before
but that will play an
important role in the proof
of the compactness--
in particular, the proof of
the existence of the limit.
And this is something where I
need to discuss martingales.
So martingale gill is
an important object
in probability theory.
And it's a random sequence.
So we'll look at discrete
sequences, so indexed
by non-negative integers.
And is martingale is
such a sequence where
if I'm interested in the
expectation of the next term
and even if you know
all the previous terms--
so you have full knowledge of
the sequence before time n,
and you want to predict
on the expectation what
the nth term is--
then you cannot do better than
simply predicting the last term
that you saw.
So this is the definition
of a martingale.
Now, to do this
formally, I need to talk
about filtrations and what
not in measured theory.
But let me not do that.
OK, so this is how
you should think
about martingales and a
couple of important examples
of martingales.
So the first one comes
from-- the reason
why these things are called
martingales is that there
is a gambling strategy
which is related
to such a sequence where
let's say you consider
a sequence of fair coin tosses.
So here's what
we're going to do.
So suppose we consider
a betting strategy.
And x sub n is equal
to your balance time n.
And suppose that we're
looking at a fair casino
where the expectation of
every game is exactly 0.
Then this is a martingale.
So imagine you have
a sequence of coin
flips, and you win $1 for each
head and lose $1 for each tail.
When you're at time five, you
should have $2 in your pocket.
Then time five
plus 1, you expect
to also have that many dollars.
It might go up.
It might go down.
But in expectation,
it doesn't change.
Is there a question?
OK.
So they're asking about,
is there some independence
condition required?
And the answer is no.
So there's no independence
condition that is required.
So the definition
of a martingale
is just if, even with complete
knowledge of the sequence up
to a certain point, the
difference going forward
is 0 in expectation.
OK, so here's another
example of a martingale,
which actually turns out to
be more relevant to our use--
namely, that if I
have some hidden--
think of x as some hidden
random variable, so something
that you have no idea.
But you can observe
it at time n based
on information up to time n.
So for example, suppose
you have no idea who
is going to win the
presidential election.
And really, nobody has any idea.
But as time proceeds, you
make an educated guess
based on the information
that you have,
all the information you
have up to that point.
And that information becomes
a larger and larger set
as time moves forward.
Your prediction is going to
be a random variable that
goes up and down.
And that will be a
martingale, because--
so how I predict
today based on what
are all the possibilities
happening going forward,
well, one of many
things could happen.
But if I knew that my prediction
is going to, in expectation,
shift upwards, then
I shouldn't have
predicted what I predict today.
I should have predicted
upwards anyway.
OK.
So this is another
construction of martingales.
So this also comes up.
You could have other more pure
mathematics-type explanations,
where suppose I
want to know what
is the chromatic number
of a random graph.
And I show you that
graph one edge at a time.
You can predict the expectation.
You can find the expectation
of this graph's statistic
based on what you've
seen up to time n.
And that sequence
will be a martingale.
An important property
of a martingale,
which is known as the
martingale convergence theorem--
and so that's what we'll need
for the proof of the existence
of the limit next time--
says that every
bounded martingale--
so for example, suppose
your martingale only
takes values between 0 and 1.
So every bounded martingale
converges almost surely.
You cannot have a martingale
which you expect to constantly
go up and down.
So I want to show you
a proof of this fact.
Let me just mention that
the bounded condition is
a little bit stronger than
what we actually need.
From the proof, you'll
see that you really only
need them to be L1 bounded.
It's enough.
And more generally,
there is a condition
called uniform integrability,
which I won't explain.
All right.
OK.
So let me show you a proof
of the martingale convergence
theorem.
And I'm going to be somewhat
informal and somewhat cavalier,
because I don't want
to get into some
of the fine details
of probability theory.
But if you have taken something
like 18.675 probability theory,
then you can fill in
all those details.
So I like this
proof, because it's
kind of a proof by gambling.
So I want to tell you a story
which should convince you that
a martingale cannot
keep going up and down.
It must converge almost surely.
So suppose x sub n
doesn't converge.
OK, so this is why
I say I'm going
to be somewhat cavalier
with probability theory.
So when I say this
doesn't converge,
I mean a specific instance of
the sequence doesn't converge
or some specific realization.
If it doesn't converge,
then there exists a and b,
both rational numbers between
0 and 1, such that the sequence
crosses the interval a,
b infinitely many times.
So by crossing this interval,
what I mean is the following.
OK.
So there's an
important picture which
will help a lot in
understanding this theorem.
So imagine I have this
time n, and I have a and b.
So I have this martingale.
It's realization curve
will be like that.
So that's an instance
of this martingale.
And by crossing, I
mean a sequence that--
OK, so here's what
I mean by crossing.
I start below a and--
let me use a different color.
So I start below a, and I
go above b and then wait
until I come back below a.
And I go above b.
Wait until I come back.
So do like that.
Like that.
So I start below a until
the first time I go above b.
And then I stop that sequence.
So those are the upcrossings
of this martingale.
So upcrossing is when
you start below a,
and then you end up above b.
So if you don't converge,
then there exists such a
and b such that there are
infinitely many such crossings.
So this is just a fact.
It's not hard to see.
And what we'll show is
that this doesn't happen
except with probability 0.
So we'll show that this
occurs with probability 0.
And because there are
only countably many
rational numbers, we find
that x sub n converges
with probability 1.
So these are upcrossings.
So I didn't define
it, but hopefully you
understood from my picture
and my description.
And let me define
by u sub n to be
the number of
upcrossings up to time
n, so the number of
such upcrossings.
Now let me consider
a betting strategy.
Basically, I want to make money.
And I want to make money by
following these upcrossings.
OK.
So every time you
give me a number and--
so think of this as
the stock market.
So it's a fair stock market
where you tell me the price,
and I get to decide,
do I want to buy?
Or do I want to sell?
So consider the betting
strategy where at any time,
we're going to hold either 0
or 1 share of the stock, which
has these moving prices.
And what we're going to do
is if xn is less than a,
is less than the lower
bound, then we're
going to buy and hold, meaning
1, until the first time
that the price reaches
above b and then
sell as soon as the first time
we see the price goes above b.
So this is the betting strategy.
And it's something
which you can implement.
If you see a sequence
of prices, you
can implement this strategy.
And you already hopefully see,
if you have many upcrossings,
then each upcrossing,
you make money.
Each upcrossing, you make money.
And this is almost
too good to be true.
And in fact, we see that the
total gain from this strategy--
so if you start with
some balance, what
you get at the end--
is at least this
difference from a
to b times the number
of upcrossings.
You might start somewhere.
You buy, and then you
just lose everything.
So there might be
an initial cost.
And that cost is
bounded, because we start
with a bounded martingale.
So suppose the martingale
is always between 0 and 1.
We start with a
bounded martingale.
But on the other hand,
there is a theorem
about martingales, which
is not hard to deduce
from the definition, that
no matter what the betting
strategy is, the gain
at any particular time
must be 0 in expectation.
So this is just the
property of the martingale.
So 0 equals the
expected gain, which
is at least b minus a
times the expected number
of upcrossings minus 1.
And thus the expected number
of upcrossings up to time n
is at most 1 over b minus a.
Now, we let n go to infinity.
And let u sub infinity be the
total number of upcrossings.
By the monotone convergence
theorem in this limit,
the limit of these u sub
n's, it can never go down.
It's always weakly increasing.
It converges to the
expectation of the total number
of upcrossings.
So now, in particular, you
know that the total number
of upcrossings is at
most some finite number.
So in particular,
the probability
that you have infinitely
many crossings is 0.
So with probability 0, you
cross infinitely many times,
which proves the
claim over there
and which concludes
the proof of the claim
that the martingale
converges almost surely.
OK, so that proves the
martingale converge theorem.
So next time, we'll
combine everything
that we did today to prove the
three main theorems that we
stated last time
on graph limits.